[Applause]
that was one of the stories the last
several days is one for eight showing
from three-point range
durant trying to draw the foul boy
tucker really getting
up and into durant tucker an
excellent defender shot blocks portis
again with the rejection
but griffith comes up with a ball brown
to harris
and a whistle blowing checking on the
shot block
yeah it shouldn't have gone back to 14.
that's what scott foster who's the crew
chief checking with ed malloy we've got
a
and played well during the regular
season hasn't played as many minutes so
far in the playoffs
but impactful ones here in game four
durant
upshot side of the backboard
back door durant hamilton got a piece of
it
and it went out of bounds but when that
bounce off the deflection the brooklyn
that's saying it still should be their
ball
kevin durant deflected by middleton
durant drives inside tripped up he
thought he was fouled
another 10-0 run by milwaukee this is a
16-point advantage
durant blocked by middleton
a gorgeous connection in the lead back
up to 14.
[Music]
[Applause]
durant tries a three he thought he was
fouled
durant ball comes out of his hands joe
harris drives inside
looking shot clock at four durant
three-pointer air ball
shot it saves it and then throws it out
of bounds
that's the 13th turnover by brooklyn the
most they've had in this series
game one nine game two nine game three
just eight
and the crowd applauding the bucks
defense once again
brown durant harris green and clacks it
out there for brooklyn
durant double team still gets the shot
off lopez the rebound
and it's a 14-point box lead he's
devastating
in the open floor and finished with
strength through contact
durant he wanted a foul up 16 and they
have frustrated kevin durant a lot of
contact
very physical you can make the case as a
foul
he's upset he's frustrated pj tucker
doing his job getting to his body
disrupting his rhythm if it's a call as
a call if it's not
i'm doing my job doing the dirty was it
fun to watch
as the bucks and the nets have gone at
each other
all afternoon the bucks playing with
that desperation to try and even the
series they have fought
nash deciding we'll fight another day
timothy luaro cavarou coming in as kevin
durant is done durant with 28 points 13
rebounds
five assists
tyler johnson shot won't go
alize johnson had it knocked out of
bounds still brooklyn ball
13 to shoot and i think scott foster's
going to change the call
[Applause]
yep